Consider a different question,
such as what is the optimal treatment
strategy among already known and
available options, or
if a particular chronic care model
was changed in a specific way,
what would the outcomes be on
clinical quality and cost.
As opposed to the classic research
question of which drug works best,
determining optimal treatment would
require many alternative experiments.
That is, trying every possible Treatment
Strategy on groups of similar patients.
To answer the second question,
an experiment could be conducted by
changing the clinical process
in half of the clinic and
comparing it to the other half
that is operated as before.
However, this would be costly and
complex to do.
These are the types of questions
best answered through modeling and
simulation using digital health data.
There are a number of techniques for
doing this.
Again, this is not an analytics course,
so we'll describe them, but
not go into the details
of how they're done.